he who make films members of the Academy
are terribly proud of the world's
serious and dedicated film makers in
their product and each year when the
Academy announces the nominations for
awards film critics and fans alike find
as much to disagree about as to agree
with which as of course as it should be
that's why we make melodramas musicals
historical pageants comedies westerns
and documentaries there is no
disagreement however that each year
films are intensified and refined and
more widely accepted as a really true
art and from an abundance of excellence
we have nominated the Academy these
films as the five best pictures of the
year Midnight Cowboy produced by Jerome
Hellman and at the thousand days
produced by Hal B Wallis
Butch Cassidy and the Sundance Kid
produced by John former C produced by
Jacques around and Hamada Sheedy Hello
Dolly
produced by Ernest Lehman the winner is
Midnight Cowboy
I'd like to thank you all very much on
behalf of everyone connected with the
making of the film with a particular
thank you to David picker and United
Artists who made it all possible thank
you